- [Voiceover] We've been
discussing the American Civil War,
which lasted from 1861 until 1865.
It was the deadliest conflict
in all of American history,
in which 620,000 Americans
lost their lives.
We briefly went over
the very end of the war,
as Grant caught up to Lee at Appomattox.
And Lee surrendered, and
then confederate sympathizer
and sometimes spy, John
Wilkes Booth assassinated
American President Abraham Lincoln.
Lincoln was followed in
office by Andrew Johnson,
who will preside over reconstruction.
But now that we've talked
about the progress of war,
from the first fighting at
Fort Sumter in April of 1861,
to the last surrenders
in November of 1865,
I'd like to take just a
few minutes to contemplate
what some of the bigger
issues that the Civil War
raises are in American History.
And what impact will it have on the future
of American life?
Well certainly one of the
most important things,
if not the most important thing
to come out of the Civil War
is the end of slavery.
You know, before the Civil
War, before the 1850s,
your average White
American, who lived in say
Pennsylvania or Kentucky,
probably wasn't very fond
of slavery, but probably
wouldn't have gone
out of his or her way to
take a stand against it.
I think Lincoln himself
was very representative
of this view, in that, he hated slavery,
but he thought that he had
no right to interfere with it
and he mostly just
wanted to make sure that
slave owners couldn't bring
enslaved people out west
to take lands from, what
he saw as hardworking,
deserving, poorer Whites.
By the end of the Civil
War, no one could argue
that African Americans,
especially in the north
did not deserve citizenship.
Throughout the Civil
War, African Americans
proved their important to the
nation, time and time again.
Especially through their
military service in units
like the 54th Massachusetts for example.
And so, for the approximately
four and a half million
enslaved people who lived in the south,
they now had their freedom.
And the story of what
happens to these people
who have been freed from bondage,
is perhaps the most interesting,
and important story of American history.
Does all men are created equal mean
all men and women are created equal?
That is the question that
will occupy the nation
in one way or another, up
until the present, really.
Another major important
takeaway from the Civil War
is that that Civil War
represented a movement
in the United States,
from a union of states
to a nation.
And you can even see how
Abraham Lincoln's thinking
on this changes over
the course of the war.
He starts to even use the word nation
more and more.
Throughout the early part of the history
of the United States, you
see this balance of power
between states and between
the Federal Government
really shifting all of the time.
You see things like the
nullification crisis in the 1830s
when South Carolina said
we don't like this tariff.
We think that as a state,
the union is composed
out of the consent of
the individual states,
and therefore the state
has the right to nullify
a law it doesn't agree with.
The same sort of situation
happened in 1860 over slavery.
The southern states
believed that Lincoln would
outlaw slavery, and thought
that it would be more
important to secede as a group of states
protecting in their words,
their states rights,
then to be subject to
the laws of the nation.
Well the Civil War ends
that kind of thinking.
In fact you even see it from
how people write the name
of this country.
Frequently it might have been
said before the Civil War
these United States.
It's a group of states that are united.
After the Civil War, it
becomes the United States.
One nation, indivisible.
And so this is the moment
when the Federal Government
really begins to grow.
You know during war time,
the north had to really
organize as a nation to provide resources
for their populace and for the soldiers
and so the President gained powers that
he had never had before,
and the Federal bureaucracy
itself grew a great deal.
And you're going to see this
throughout the 20th century,
really up until the 1970s
that the Federal Government
in the United States is going
to have more and more power.
A third important takeaway
from the Civil War
is that during the Civil
War the north industrialized
to produce all of the goods
and material that the
north needed to succeed.
They built factories, and railroads
and those factories and railroads,
and all the rest of the
impressive engineering
that went into winning the war
is then going to be turned toward making
an industrial behemoth
in the post war era.
So, a lot of things that
started during the Civil War
in terms of national
industrialization really carry
on in the post war era,
known as the Gilded Age.
That help the United
States become the worlds
premiere industrial
power, and later, based
on that industrial
power, one of the worlds
premiere political powers.
Another thing that is
not often talked about
with the Civil War is
the growing role of women
in the United States polity.
Ya know in the American Civil War,
at first it was very taboo
for a woman of good birth
to go and become a nurse.
But as the war progressed, that kind of
Victorian thinking, believing
that a woman belonged
only to a very feminine and
domestic sphere of life,
really had to fade away
in the face of the
reality that women needed
to play a role in the war.
In the north women became nurses.
They helped to chair the
American Sanitary Commission,
which was one of the key hospital groups
of the time period.
And in the south, many
women also really took over
the running of family farms
as White men went away,
White women, poorer
White women for example
would be in charge of a farm themselves.
A White woman who belonged
to a slave owning family
herself, would then have
charge of enslaved people.
So women took a much
more leading role during
the Civil War.
After the Civil War,
some of that falls away.
In fact, there's a really difficult moment
in the movement for women's rights when
in 1870, the 15th amendment
granted African American
men the right to vote, but not women.
And so the women's movement
will take some time
to regroup in the late 19th century.
But the Civil War, like many later wars,
brought women outside the home.
And after the war they were
not anxious to go back there.
They became involved in many
charitable organizations,
often known as social housekeeping.
As women do more and more
things outside the home.
Which will eventually grow
into the women's movement
of the early 20th
century, and lead to women
getting the right to vote.
This is just a small
sampling of some of the
major impacts that the Civil
War had on the United States.
Often when we think about
United States history,
we think about it cutting
off at the Civil War.
Most college courses
or high school courses
are organized the US before the Civil War,
and the US after the Civil War,
because it's a really
defining moment in our
nations history for these reasons,
and for many others.
The United States entered the Civil War
a loose union of states
divided by territory
and beliefs, and exited the
Civil War a single nation.
Modern, industrial, peopled
by an incredibly diverse
range of citizens from all over the world.
In other words, after the Civil War,
the United States will
really come into its own.
And that's because the Civil
War was the moment when
the United States grew up.
The United States in 1870,
looked a lot more like
the year 1900, then it did the year 1860.
The 13th amendment, and later
the 14th and 15th amendments
ruled that people of African
descent were citizens
of the United States.
Remember, beforehand,
enslaved people in the south
counted for only 3/5ths of a person,
and that person couldn't vote,
move freely, or own his or her own labor,
not to mention their own life.
The Civil War decided
once and for all that
everyone born in the United States
was a United States citizen.
But what citizenship really
meant for African Americans,
for women, for Native
Americans and immigrants,
even for Whites.
Was still something that
would be hammered out
through the rest of the
19th century and the 20th.
After the Civil War, the
old problems of sectional
tension and states
rights, were put to rest,
but they were replaced by new problems.
Problems of modern America.
Industrialization, poverty, immigration,
and so is the guns of
the Civil War fell quiet,
the United States embarked
into a new era, The Gilded Age.